I gotta tell you I feel like they found
the right guy pit to host perennial
nuestro because I feel like every time
you're around it's a party am i right
you know for one put him in or throw you
know much about that means man thank you
very much the opportunity but what
better than to throw a party in the 305
miami-dade County the Magic City where
what happens in Miami never happened and
then it got mr. 305 I think they got it
right not the Super Bowl halftime but
they got it right though I'm gonna tell
you I listen and I gotta say one time
for Talia to be she's amazing I was
gonna say you actually have two
beautiful co-hosts with you this entire
summer exactly hmm
but you know I gotta know what tricks
you have up your sleeve because I know
you're no stranger to hosting shows but
this is your first time hosting flame
your own restaurant not I never have a
chicken on the sleeve to be honest with
you because just some things happen that
happen they happen naturally yeah that's
the way I like it I like it to be real
okay that's I think that is a real magic
trick you know especially living in
society was a lot of fake things going
on you got to worry about another
Photoshop he is 100% genuine there you
go update to legend I did hear a little
brie did tell me John Travolta might
stop by your home look at that
man I'll tell you the thing is with when
you're doing legendary things
legends may pop up okay when you're on
your way to be a legend an icon yeah you
have to surround yourself you some of
your friends and I'll show your future
how about that there you go
let's talk about your new friend and
your new music Blake Shelton because
this new cloud I cannot get out of my
head man I can't get ready
hmm get ready bangable mm-hmm okay ready
I told you I could get it listen you're
mr. worldwide and you're literally
bridging Miami and Oklahoma like how did
this come about Miami Oklahoma slash
Nashville because we we did the video in
Nashville and obviously big shout out to
everybody in Oklahoma yeah as far as
bringing Miami to it just goes to show
you everybody all the time music is the
ultimate thing that the ultimate thing
that unites unites everybody doesn't
divide you know so to be able to do
something with Blake Shelton oh man
we're off to another planet now and we
got one coming up with Tim McGraw we got
some coming up with Jimmy Buffett we
working with Shania Twain oh you try to
take over Nashville oh no not at all I'm
just gonna learn
through music calibre a collaboration to
me that's been how can I say I go back
to the best way to unite I love that so
you wouldn't consider this a specific
genre it's just you just working with
the people you want to work with no it's
just music I think everybody tries to
put things in John Roos and categorize
things and create these crazy metrics
for it but when you're doing what you
love to do when you're having fun it's
just music folks and at this point we're
gonna call it global music you perform
get ready actually Superbowl weekend
right here right we did it at a tailgate
party it was great yeah I would love to
see it during the halftime show I'm not
gonna lie no you just don't know that
does great I want to say congratulations
to Jennifer Shakira valving Bunny and to
me things like things of that nature
just goes to show your common sense it's
not that common the only thing that
common sense don't know anytime that
common sense is really that common if
it's the rapper / actor from Chicago one
time for common sense he's the only one
that took in common sense and made it
common it would be common sense to get
you the headline slot at a Super Bowl
halftime show yeah you know I'm one to
owning teams and performing at the
halftime show but yeah I appreciate all
the opportunities and now we can start
opening talks about opening about owning
a piece of the Dolphins there you go
thank you I appreciate he's building an
empire a business here yes I do want to
get your thoughts on something cuz
obviously we lost so great Kobe Bryant I
know it's hard for everyone especially
you
what did Kobe mean to you I mean Kobe
wasn't a personal friend to be honest
which is just someone that we all looked
up to and take my glasses off for that
one he is somebody that embodies what
hard work is you know they always say
practice makes perfect and perfect
doesn't exist but he was right there you
know because he worked so hard for it
and I hope that this is more than a
moment and it's more of a movement and I
tell people all the time live life don't
let life live you and people are caught
up all the time on what the pictures
look like what this looks like it's like
people are so connected they're
disconnected and they're taking so many
pictures they're missing the big picture
so I'm hoping that with what the tragedy
that happened to Kobe becomes a blessing
for the world and someone like he
sacrificed for us to take a step back
and go guys
enjoy this ride and to Kobe into the
family our prayers go out to them but
more than anything
and not only to the data - you know it's
someone saw a catch-22 do you it's a
touchy subject to speak about I would
say but I will tell you this
then legacy that he left behind his
energy will forever be here the body is
just a vehicle
everybody's gonna live forever with with
with Kobe Kobe's gonna live forever with
us and I go back to that man live life
don't let life live you love life and
life will love you you know there's
someone else whose death also made any
life really made a huge impact on the
culture and that's Celine I can thin the
anger actually pay tribute to her at
Selina 25 in Texas right what did it
mean to be a part of that I mean that's
an icon of legend and she forever lives
with us I mean look sometimes those kind
of things happen to give other
opportunities to to those that have also
gone and touches the world example
without what happened to Selena there
wouldn't be a Jennifer Lopez it to a
certain extent you know I was an amazing
opportunity for her to be able to show
Hollywood and what what she is and when
she brings to the table representing a
powerful woman latina no baby I will
munch up weight up on a soda and open a
lot of doors for us so it's a true honor
and these kind of moments they're
priceless so sometimes you know what
you're living them it's hard to
recapture them once you go through with
it then you you sit back and you go wow
what a moment
you can reflect to me like I did it's
truly an honor and I look forward to it
[Music]